你知道吗
台湾有一种病
最烧钱
光是一年
就要烧掉
530亿
健保费
有快10万的人
天天都在烧钱
是哪一种病啊
就是慢性肾脏病
太夸张了吧
景气差就算了
还要把你的
钱都 洗进医院去
不划算
怎么样来顾好你的肾
远离肾脏病
马上告诉你
胡乃文开讲啰
我是你的老朋友胡医师
吃水果别乱吃
肾脏病吃一口恐丧命
肾脏不好的人注意听喔
肾功能不好洗肾
或肾脏病患者
不要吃
杨桃
连杨桃干
杨桃汁也不要吃
有的人吃了可能就中毒
严重的话还会
死掉了
这5种人最危险
为了健康一口
都不要吃
1慢性肾脏病第三期以上的人
2急性肾脏病恢复期的人
3洗肾病人
4单侧肾脏切除手术
还没有满六个月的人
5尿毒症的人
杨桃对肾脏不好吗
为什么会中毒
杨桃里头有一种神经毒素
叫做Caramboxin
身体健康的人
吃杨桃没问题
但是肾功能差的人
吃了杨桃没办法代谢
毒素一直累积
就会直攻脑里头的神经
出现打嗝呕吐抽搐
甚至于昏迷死亡
最可怕的是
没有药可以解这种毒
万一肾不好的人
不小心吃到了
杨桃怎么办
立刻找医生别拖了
像我们健康的人
也会担心
杨桃一天可以吃几颗呀
拜托了不要吃几颗好不好
你一天吃三四片没问题
但是吃一整颗就多了
更不建议
空腹
或者天天吃喔
因为杨桃它里头草酸多
草酸会影响钙的吸收
而且草酸会跟钙结合
成为草酸结石
甚至还会伤到你的骨头
后面我会告诉你
肾脏病人的饮食禁忌
要看到最后喔
泡澡＋按腰后1穴
排毒逆转肾
肾脏病最可怕的是
早期几乎没有症状
有六成的人一检查就晚期了
我临床上看到的病人
肾功能受损比较严重
就会见到这几种现象
一身上有尿骚味
二嘴唇黑
三有口臭
四舌头暗红
五舌苔厚白脏的
慢性肾脏病
最爱找上这三种人
糖尿病高血压痛风的人
洗肾的患者里面糖友最多
所以一定要好好的控制
不然肾脏提早报销
就大大麻烦了
肾脏不好的人怎么改善
来给你两个
简单的养肾法
你是健康的人
可以养肾预防肾脏病
有肾脏病的人
你就能够
促进血液循环帮助排毒
第一个养肾法
按摩肾俞穴
能够补肾益精
改善肾脏血液循环
肾俞穴在肚脐正后方
脊椎左右两边
大概两指宽的宽度
你每天按摩它个3分钟
补肾益精
促进血液循环
暖呼呼又舒服
第二个养肾法
就是泡澡
中医看肾脏病
常把它当成水肿来治疗
水肿分成两种
腰以下
腰以上
金匮要略里头记载
在腰部以下的水肿
就要靠多排尿来治疗
在腰以上的水肿
就要靠出汗来治疗
泡澡就是最简单的发汗方式
一位肾脏科医生分享病例
有一位八十多岁的老太太
肾丝球过滤率只剩下16
按时吃药以外
还搭配早晚泡澡15分钟
三个月之后
肾丝球体滤过滤升到了40
血压恢复正常
全身酸痛也改善了
是不是很棒
冬天泡澡很舒服
把身体里的毒素
和重金属等等出汗排出去
也是很好的护肾方法之一
人到一个年纪
油要挑
脾气要收
接下来
进一段广告
介绍一款很懂你的苦茶油
5个习惯再不改易拖垮肾
全世界洗肾人口最多的国家
你知道在哪里吗
跟你说就是我们台湾
洗肾有快十万人
慢性肾脏病的人有270万人
就是说每八个人里头
就有一个人肾脏不健康
实在很夸张
想避免洗肾
5个习惯先改一改
一爱吃高油高盐加工食品
二蛋白质吃过量
三不爱喝水
四乱吃止痛药保健食品
五高压与熬夜
我们先讲第一个
爱吃高油高盐加工食品
拉面
泡面
热狗
火腿
这些食物吃起来
香喷喷对不对
常常吃你会得到血压升高
肾脏血流变差
肾小管会比超商店员还要忙
每天都在超时加班
加班久了撑不住了
你可以怎么做
多吃新鲜的原型的食物
高盐食物加工食品
尽量是排去在外吧
太咸的泡面汤
还有拉面汤
不要整碗都把它喝完
喝两口满足就好了
第二个蛋白质吃过量
减肥健身的人注意
蛋白质代谢
会产生很多的含氮的废物
像氨之类的
都要靠肾脏来过滤排毒
长期的蛋白质吃过量
肾脏就会被你操坏了
一天要吃多少的蛋白质
才不会太多呢
有人建议说
成人每天的蛋白质量
大概抓个体重乘以0.8克就好了
吃太多
反而让肾脏负担太大了
第三个不爱喝水
你上厕所的时候
看一下你的尿液
如果颜色比较偏黄
表示水喝得太少了
这样一来就容易尿液太浓
结石感染
都容易发生
不要以为水只能解渴
它能帮助你的
肾脏代谢毒素
像防腐剂人工添加物等等
怎么样喝才对呢
少量多次喝
白开水
才是最实际的养肾法
第四个
乱吃止痛药保健食品
前卫生署副署长李龙腾先生
曾经说过
全世界没有健康食品
他自己根本不吃这些
他还指出
台湾和日本的
洗肾率居高不下
跟大家过度依赖健康食品
一定有大关系
因为健康食品
本质上
算是加工的食品
吃太多肾脏
也会拼命工作负担超重
至于止痛药
有些人腰酸背痛
就去药房买贴布
或者是买止痛药吃
我建议你
如果你是偶尔
腰酸背痛不舒服
使用贴布以后
没有明显的缓解
一定要赶紧找医生
帮你看一看
第五个高压和熬夜
晚睡熬夜的人啊
你是不是本来应该
从从容容游刃有余
的上床睡觉
现在却是
匆匆忙忙连滚带爬
的上床
你看看有一位
蔡依林小姐
她过去几乎天天熬夜
直到被皮蛇所缠身
就带状疱疹了
现在晚上九点半
乖乖的早早就去睡觉
健康找回来了
皮肤变得更是水
当当长期熬夜压力大
血压血糖容易失控
肾脏还得拼命为你加班
嘿别等到肾脏报销
才花大钱来治病
太伤你的荷包了
对不对啊
百天不吃一物
恢复肾脏健康
肾功能不好的人
我跟你说
第一件要注意的事就是
不要吃重咸的
吃太咸吃重咸
会怎么样呢
让肾脏过劳
身体的盐份太高
肾脏就得要拼命
把它排出去
肾丝球肾小管都拼命工作
连带的血压也会升高
加速肾功能的恶化
甚至于提高肾脏病的风险
肾功能受损
真的能靠饮食来逆转
二十多年前
我岳母被医生
检查出肾功能异常
我太太急着问我怎么办
我跟她说
把岳母的饮食调整一下
我说一百天不要加盐
不要加酱
结果呢
我岳母真的在一百天之后
肾功能恢复正常喔
医宗金鉴
杂病心法要诀里头
有这么一句话
他说若能戒盐酱
淡食百日多有生者
什么意思啊
就是戒盐戒酱
大概一百天还有很多人
都可以继续存活
就这个意思
慢性肾脏病的人
不妨你明天就开始来试试看
肾功能健康的人
用这两招保护肾脏
第一酱料分开放
第二用天然食材当香料
你在点餐的时候
跟店员说
酱料少一点
或者是酱料分开放
这样子你可以自己决定
我要沾的份量是多少
二用天然食材当香料
喜欢自己料理的人
建议你少用鸡汤块
改用天然食材
洋葱蒜头香菇
当汤底
炒菜可以用
九层塔姜葱蒜胡椒
来代替化学调料品
这样肾脏保养好了
吃起来身体也更舒服
肾脏病人怎么吃
3水果5蔬菜放心吃
肾脏病人最关心的就是
到底什么能吃什么不能吃
从中医古籍戒盐酱的理论
我们可以延伸出来
肾脏病人要避免
吃吃 味道浓重过咸过辣过酸过甜
等等所谓的
厚味的食物
这些食物容易
增加肾脏的负担
让肾功能恶化的更快
有3种食物
建议肾脏病人少吃或不吃
一加工肉品肉松香肠培根
二加工食品泡面洋芋片蜜饯
三腌渍食品泡菜酱瓜榨菜
那么肾脏病人
在蔬果上有哪些禁忌
肾脏病人可以吃的蔬菜有哪些
高丽菜花椰菜豆芽菜丝瓜茭白笋
肾脏病人可以吃的水果有哪些
芭乐苹果还有蓝莓
肾脏病人需要限制的蔬菜就是
菠菜地瓜叶马铃薯番茄
它们都是因为钾太高了
需要少吃或汆烫
去掉那个钾之后再吃
需要限制的水果奇异果香蕉
绝对不能吃的水果杨桃
提醒你肾脏病人的饮食
要以个人状况
来调整最安全的做法
我建议你还是
请医生帮你评估
才不会吃错
又能够顾好你的肾脏